welcome an angel Cameron Diaz
hello the oscar-winning writer-director
team behind Fargo Barton Fink and the
man who wasn't there Joel and Ethan Coen
who are famous for their dark comic
vision offer a uniquely light-hearted
view of art direction for as long as the
medium has existed the debate has raged
our movies art or entertainment
well how many movies these days are
entertaining yes movies are an art but
the person who directs this art that
movies are who was formerly called the
art director is now confusingly called
the production designer the production
designer directs the work of the person
currently called the art director and is
himself usually a former art director
who has gotten too big for his britches
but specifically what does the
production designer do well he or she
flits about the set draping things and
fabric hanging pictures on the wall or
if it's a world war two picture
arranging the mud
everything you see on screen except for
the actors who don't matter so much
is designed by the production designer
or if he didn't design it he at least
looked at it and said okay we'll go with
that
we honor than these strange artistic
people the nominees for the best art
direction are for Amelie art direction
by Alene bennetto and set decoration by
Mary larvae the Gosford Park art
direction by Steven Altman and set
decoration by Anakin
the Harry Potter and the Sorcerer's
Stone art direction by Stewart Craig and
set decoration by Stephanie McMillan for
the Lord of the Rings the Fellowship of
the Ring our direction by grant major
and set decoration by Dan Hoonah
the Moulin Rouge our direction by
Catherine Martin and set decoration by
Bridget Brooke and the Oscar goes to
Catherine Martin from long
this is the second Oscar for Catherine
Martin this evening in the first four
digit dock they were both nominated in
1997 for their work on another
film William Shakespeare's Romeo and
Juliet
another little scrap of paper thank you
again to the Academy thank you to mr.
Ian Gracie and his colleagues the best
art director and art department in the
world who with his team of craftsmen
managed to create the physical world of
Mullah Rouge entirely on sound stages in
my hometown of Sydney Australia - mr.
McAlpin an artist and a teacher I thank
you and two bears you come up with ideas
that even I sometimes think are crazy
but you've taught me to live the dream
that anything is possible through ideas
hard work and discipline thank you for
letting me come on this journey with you
you are my other half this is for you
thank you and thank you to my family all
my friends
this is the first movie I have seen in
my life who influenced me a lot
the only problem was that we did not
have money to pay 20 so we have seen the
movie summertime outside behind the
screen and we have read everything in
the opposite way not banher but brunette
and i repeated for years my favorite
movies rule AB a Roman Empire Jesus I
was flabbergasted upon this movie
ruining my favorite movie thank you very
much brunette
Nathan Lane the Oscar for Best
Supporting Actor the Academy Awards
return
you